很喜欢的月
今天呢 我就是想分享一下
我是怎么样
以后 其实我还想的酸
然后让自己投入
有动机变成现在这种水光机
然后 我知道有很多的姐妹
开始很怕用酸的
因为之前门可能用过酸的就是
一用酸的酸的酸的酸
用酸的包豆
等我今天是想分享我自己的一个
用酸的方法
就你还知道我的这个方法
还基本上很少会翻车
而且你会感觉
连知道那个闭口粉丝越来越少
然后皮膩越好
那我用酸很少翻车的这个金腿
就在于我酸很酥脱
我是同时一起做的
很多人觉得用酸之后皮膚很刺痕
甚至饭红翻车都是因为
这种有多好
那我现在给你们展示了
我用一个酸的精华来做展示吧
那一般我用了
我比较猛的酸的之前
那我都会用一个
酥脱精华去做一个全练的达酒
有一些酸呢
它是说要在洗完练之后
第一不用到
那这样的酸你就根据它的这个官方的指示
用完之后
你再用一个这种酸酥脱精华
去配葛达水面
再图一点腰开
那两上有豆腀的时候
我比较长用的是这个酸酸酸
因为它配合酸的黄豆腀
你消得比较快
那如果里面没有豆腀的话
就用别的酸酸酸酸的腰开
那现在用酸酸酸酸的达酒
这一步就是相当于我们的皮膚
在你起你照顾不行的保护膜
它可以很大的传终
这样的笛饭车的节目
好 这段我前面已经
用休护茶的大锅底了
再用一个一样的酸
我已经在我脸上洗收了之后
再一次的用这种酒口的面串
去保护护的皮膚
就面上我脸上会全面都有的
那你如果跟我一样这样用酸
其实很少的饭车
我们就相当于是给皮膚上了
两层保护照
然后在用酸的时候
不要一开始就用一个脱面膜的酸
那这样皮膚肯定会受不了的
我们要群续剑进的去用
满粒度短时间的去逐步建立一个
耐受
那我分享一个耐受剑的计划表
我们可以截图
大家对照着来去用酸就可以
然后再分享计划比较是个新手的酸
那大家不要觉得说
若门的酸是不是效果都不好
这计划新手的酸是我用
加来发现它们是六文河
然后稍微很好的
这样这个还用这个
还有这款这一款
它们都是很溫和成是个新手的
大家根据支持的预算去选就可以了
然后我再分享这个梦一点的
这样这个
然后刚才我的这个
还有这个
很多是属于比较某一点的酸
这就快我已经用了很久了
它们可以让我再断时间的变成那种
用戏用滑的水光级
像我现在皮膚对于酸已经很耐受了
那如果我感觉最近皮膚
比较有处操
那我的选择不会是说
我要去用一个几千块钱的
会计划
一定会用这种比较某一点的酸去
给皮膚进行个凸击
基本上两三千块的皮膚
就可以恢复成那种
幸迷然后有光泽的样子